こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
本日はなんと！
あの有名アプリ
白猫プロジェクトが本日をもちまして
２周年ということでございます！
おめでとうございます
僕ものんびりプレイしてやがてもう１年以上経つかな
もう一年以上もやってるんだね！
１年以上も白猫プロジェクトをやってるんですけども
そんなにランクは上がっておりません･･･
でもまぁ、１１５くらいまではランク来てるんで
という訳で今回は白猫プロジェクトにちなんだちょっとスペシャルなことをしていこうと思います
白猫プロジェクト、僕からして何が凄い特徴的かと言いますと
まぁ、ゲーム性とか
プレイング性
物語の 面白さとかも あるんですけども
一番はなんと！
(効果音)ヒュンヒュンヒュン
はい、という訳でキャラクターが全員
とても、可愛いんです！！
もう新キャラ出る度に僕はもうね
ドキドキしながらガチャを回す訳でございますが
まぁ、何を隠そう
僕の！
シャルロットでございます！！
うわーーー！！
僕は今まで存在するシャルロットを全て
持っております
こっちから普通のシャルロット
お正月シャルロット
茶熊のシャルロット
全員持っております
そして！
全員限界突破しております
という訳で今回私はシャルロットが推しキャラなんですけども
今回二周年ということで
私(わたくし)今回
シャルロットの！
とまでは行きません
今回ですね
紙粘土を…？＄％＆♯！％＆？＠
紙粘土を１２キロ分準備しました！！
こちらの紙粘土１２キロ分と
大量の針金を準備したので
こちらを組み合わせて
１２キロ分の
なるべく大きなシャルロットを
名付けて！
はじめしゃちょー
極上の動画になること間違いない
いやもうシャルロットの顔とか体つきとかも全部
もうインプットされてますから
かならクオリティーは高くなると思います
ではやっていこう！！
はい、という訳で作っていきましょう
シャルロットこんな感じでございます
茶熊のシャルロットですね
マントがすんげぇことになっているなぁ・・・
マントはぁ・・・取ってあげましょう
ホントねぇ、シャルロットの良さをちょっと語るよ
見た目はねぇ、ちょっとチャラそうなんすよね
がぁがぁこう色々言ってきそうな元気系女の子だなぁと思ったら
超！ぐうたら系
何をするにもめんどくさくてなるべく　コタツに入ってたいような女の子なんですよ
そのギャップがたまんない♡
なのに強いんすよ！！
双剣に関してはここ最近強化が入りましたからね
もうこの双剣の茶熊のシャルロットに関しては強いんすよ！
いやぁもう双剣に強化が入ってまたこのシャルロットが見直されたんで僕はとても嬉しいく感じております
ちょっと愛をこめて頑張って作っていきましょう
一先ず何をしなければいけないかというと
シャルロットの足組みを作りましょう
針金で頑張ってとりあえず足の感じを作りだして
ある程度形で良いんですよ
足の形が出来ればもうＯＫです
こんな感じっす
足
骨組みなので適当でいいですここは
これで足が二本完成しました
こっからっすね
足はだいぶぽくなってきましたね
まだちょっと甘いので、フレーム自体もうちょっとしめましょう
足はこんなものでいいのではないでしょうか
次は一先ずスカートだな
いや、胴体だ！
・・・・・・・・・・
OK, ok,  こいう感じです
でシャルロット双剣なので
背中からこの二本の刃はそのまま双剣になると思うんで
見栄え的にそんな悪くはならないはず・・・
胴は大体こんな感じでございます
立たないんですけどもぉ
紙粘土を付け次第で少しマシになればいいと思っております
ちょっと紙粘土を付けていきまっしょう
！！
いい感じだねぇ
たったったったったったった立つねぇ
このままちょっととりあえずこの状態で肉付けをしていきます
これなんて言えばいいのかなぁ・・・
ま、とりあえずご覧くださいどうぞ！
はっはっはっはっ
あのぉー
まぁ分かりますよね！？
どう見てもシャルロットってのは分かるので
まぁ、一先ず上手くいったんじゃないですかね？
大体サイズ的には
おいらの･･･
２分の１サイズか！
多分シャルロットの普通の大きさの２分の１のサイズでございます
普通に家に飾っておきたいんだけど
良い感じで紙粘土でシャルロットが作れたのではないでしょうか
僕のシャルロット愛が伝わったと思います！多分
本当はね腰に双剣があるんですけどぉ
ちょっと鉄パイプの関係でここからになっちゃったのがちょっと残念ですね
まるで、バニーガールみたいになっちゃった
ヴェ！
なんかでも作ってて楽しかったですもう普通に
やっぱ好きなキャラクターだと愛着が湧くんで
もう自然と手が動いてしまいました
キャラクターが全員可愛いの凄い、こう、愛着を持ってゲームを楽しむことが出来ます！
じゃぁな！